- DAVE, I GOT TO TELL YOU, MAN,
I'M REALLY HAPPY
TO BE HANGING OUT WITH YOU.
THIS IS NICE.
- OH, MAN,
IT'S JUST BEEN GREAT, MAN.
- WELL, SAME HERE, MAN.
YOU BUSY WITH YOUR SHOW.
I GOT MY STUFF.
THIS IS REALLY COOL.
- YEAH, MAN, YOU SEE,
THAT'S THE THING
WITH BLACK ACTORS, MAN.
WE NEED TO JUST UNIFY.
WE CAN'T JUST BE OUT LIKE--
- EXACTLY.
- HEY, HOLD UP, WAYNE,
I THINK YOU PASSED OUR TURN.
THE RESTAURANT'S
BACK THAT WAY.
- NAH, THAT'S ALL RIGHT.
RELAX.
- WHAT, YOU GOING
TO GET SOME WEED?
- [laughs]
NO.
- YOU GONNA GET SOME WEED,
HOLLA AT YOUR BOY.
I KNOW THE SPOT.
- HOLD ON.
- ALL RIGHT.
- THERE HE IS.
BREAK YOURSELF, FOOL!
- AWW, (BLEEP),
IT'S WAYNE BRADY, SON!
[gunfire]
- OH!
OH!
WHAT THE (BLEEP) YOU DOING?
- RIVERSIDE, MOTHA(BLEEP)!
- GODDAMN!
- [cackles]
- WHAT THE (BLEEP)
ARE YOU DOING?
- DAVE, CALM DOWN.
- WHAT YOU MEAN, CALM DOWN?
YOU JUST--
- DAVE, RELAX.
- YOU JUST SHOT PEOPLE, WAYNE!
- DAVE, DAVE.
- THOSE WERE PEOPLE YOU SHOT!
GODDAMN, MAN, YOU GOT
A DAYTIME EMMY, NIGGA.
YOU AIN'T SUPPOSED TO BE
DOIN' (BLEEP) LIKE THIS.
- DAVE, YOU MAKING ME NERVOUS.
YOU MAKING ME THINK
THAT YOU GONNA SNITCH.
NOW, YOU'RE NOT GONNA
SNITCH, RIGHT?
- NO, MAN, COME ON, NOW,
I AIN'T NO SNITCH.
- NOW, YOU SURE
YOU'RE NOT GONNA SNITCH?
- IT'S ME, NIGGA,
IT'S DAVE, BABY.
- MOTHER(BLEEP),
YOU GONNA SNITCH ON ME?
- YO, NIGGA, COME ON.
IT'S ME, IT'S DAVE.
WE BLACK ACTORS, MAN,
WE GOT TO STICK TOGETHER.
WE BLACK ACTORS.
I AIN'T GONNA SNITCH ON YOU.
COME ON, IT'S ME, BABY.
IT'S DAVE.
IT'S DAVE CHAPPELLE.
IT'S YOUR BOY.
- OKAY.
SORRY, MAN.
- I GOT TO GET
SOME MONEY, MAN.
I GOT TO GO TO THE ATM.
I DON'T HAVE NO MONEY.
- I'LL GET SOME MONEY.
ALL RIGHT,
RIGHT HERE.
- WHERE'S THE ATM AT?
- WE AT IT.
HEY!
[car horn plays
"La Cucaracha"]
- HEY, DADDY.
- HOES, DAVE.
DAVE, HOES.
- GOOD EVENING, BITCHES.
- WE DID GOOD TONIGHT.
- THAT'S WHAT I LIKE TO HEAR.
THAT'S--
OH, THAT'S NICE.
HEY, BABY!
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT,
MORE POWER TO ME.
[laughs]
ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU, BABY.
OH--OH, RAQUEL,
WHAT'S THIS?
MR. FRANKLIN'S LONELY.
HE'S--
THERE'S ONLY--
- SORRY, DADDY.
- WHAT DO YOU MEAN,
"SORRY, DADDY?"
WHAT THE HELL DID--
IS WAYNE BRADY
GONNA HAVE TO CHOKE A BITCH?
I'M GONNA HAVE TO GET OUT
OF THIS CAR AND CHOKE--
I'M NOT VIOLENT.
I TRY NOT TO BE.
I'M A--
YOU KNOW WHAT?
- WAYNE, COME ON, MAN.
COME ON, WAYNE.
- NO, NO, NO, I'M GONNA
GET OUTTA THIS CAR RIGHT NOW.
- COME ON, WILL YOU PLEASE--
PLEASE, MAN?
COME ON, JUST--
JUST LET IT SLIDE.
- [exhales]
YOU BETTER THANK
DAVE CHAPPELLE.
GO AHEAD.
- THANK YOU, DAVE,
AND I LIKE YOUR SHOW.
- RUN, BITCH!
RUN FOR YOUR LIFE!
GET SOME HELP!
I'M JUST PLAYING AROUND.
YOU KNOW.